فنظره للاوضاع وغياب الرعايه الصحيه وغياب
المستشفيات
وكثر المجاعات وانتشار الاوبئه والفيروسات
والنزلات المعويه كنت اشوف كل يوم تقريبا
10 ل 20 طفل عني في الخيمه الشخصيه تبعتي
فقررت افتح مبادره لعلاج الاطفال في
المخيم انا موجود حاليا مخيم المواصي اكبر
مخيم نزوح في قطاع غزه مدينه
رفع ايش بشكي ير السخونه مش عارف
حب مرتين في اليوم عشان الاحتقان والرشح
اللي
عندك نستقبل يوميا ما يقارب من 200 لى 300
حاله معظم الحالات بتكون عباره عن امراض
مزمنه وامراض جهاز تنفسي وامراض النازلات
المعويه بالاضافه للامراض الجلديه كامرا
الجرب والفطريات والى
ذلك وجيت تعالج و لقينا الخ اليمه الطبيه
هنا والحمد لله اللي موجوده خيمه طبيه
للاطفال وللكبار السن وللناس المرضى ما
فيش
مستشفيات كنا غد مرضى كنا عيانين يعني انا
جوزي تعبان مش قادر يصل يتحكم ولا قادرين
نوصله وصلات صعبه
كثير بنا حالات حروق حالات غرز اصابات من
الشارع في بيجينا مصابين بالقدم السكري
بيكون عندهم جروح بس بنحول على العيادات
لانه هنا المنطقه زي ما انت شايف يعني
الادوات
محدوده يعني العدد كبير مش بس علاج كمان
صرف فاحن بنحاول ان احنا قد ما نقدر ان
نحن يعني نغطي الاحتياجات
هذه الامور يوميا ازدهاء شديد عدد حالات
الناس لانه مستشفى اقرب مستشفى عننا هنا
مستشفى الكويتي بد يعني تقريبا ساعه فاحنا
هذه يمكن اقرب منطقه لمنطقه المواص ل تحشد
الناس يعني المنطقه هذه فيها اظاظ كبير من
الناس تقريبا 80% 90% من الاطفال عندهم
اسهال اسهال واستفراغ زائد الاوبئه التهاب
الكبد الوبائي ايه اصبح الحين وباء حسب
وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه 80% من اطفال غزه
عندهم التهاب الكبد الوبائي ايه
شطز
انته